so we've got the motorola z10 today and
this the stone is kind of interesting
because it does some cool things
especially when you when you slide it
open its up it's a slider from motorola
and it does this ooh breaks in the
middle yeah and I'm not so I'm not such
a big fan of the breaking I've never had
something that you intentionally have to
break yeah what I mean like wasn't it
like more comfortable and you'll hell it
up here like so it definitely is but if
you notice it sort of has this
flimsiness to it yeah but you usually
don't want an a piece of hardware that's
what it's called hardware yes right like
I literally think like after having this
for like a week or two you're gonna snap
and break it yeah I mean in some way you
know i pocketed the thing for about a
week and you know kind of coming in out
of the pocket was pretty normal but
every time I did that every time you pop
it open you kind of think this is just
not gonna last it's not gonna last yeah
for very much longer yeah oh no they're
I mean they're basically marketing this
thing as you know a mini film studio in
your pocket which and I think anytime
you do that you know you're kind of
setting the bar really high yeah so you
know if it doesn't any little minor
annoyances are going to be that much
more difficult to sort of come to terms
with the camera is you know 3.2
megapixels yeah it's pretty standard as
far as stills go you're going to get 30
frames per second for video which is not
bad i mean it's not not amazing but you
know for youtube it's pretty solid um
but in terms of sort of the software it
it was a little buggy I mean it crashed
on me more than once which is kind of
annoying but it's you know in theory
really pretty fun you know you take your
Clips you put them together you story
boredom you can do you know fade to
black you know in theory I can see what
they're going for um I just I feel like
this is just sort of the first version
of a phone that could be really awesome
what do you think of the menu I mean
don't you menu the maybes little time
the menus a little tired it's a little
bit hard to navigate around and in fact
well last night we were trying to
bluetooth a picture from this camera to
my computer and it
what it took us a good 25 minutes just
to kind of scroll around within the men
to get through the main because menus
are a little on you to side so you know
it's five hundred dollars but that's a
lot so that's directly from Motorola and
you can use it with any GS gsm right yes
just okay so you can use it with any gsm
carrier yeah okay but that's still 500
oh it's the only found Ross so if you
were to add a sign a rating to this
which I've got no one through dell 1
through 10 rating yeah I believe that's
my job that's of your job you know I'm
probably gonna give it a 5 out of 10 5 I
don't love it I don't find it to be the
best thing that's out there I think it's
the start of a potentially really cool
line for motorola but you know i think
you're kind of paying an early adopter
price for a piece of hardware that's
just not fully realized yeah it's just
that's the impression I get to it's just
not quite fully baked yet but i bet a
future versions of this phone like I
said before will be fantastic definitely
worth watching yeah definitely so that's
the motorola z10
you